leading the nation in a moment of
collective mourning to mark one of the
most painful moments
of his premiership today the number of
deaths recorded from kovid
in the uk has surpassed a hundred
thousand
and it's hard to compute the sorrow
contained in that
grim statistic the years
of life lost the family gathering is not
attended and
for so many relatives the missed chance
even
to say goodbye i offer my deepest
condolences
to everyone who's lost a loved one
using wartime oratory to help summon
solidarity
create heroes and focus blame on the
unseen
enemy and to all those who grieve we
make this pledge
that when we've come through this crisis
we will
come together as a nation to remember
everyone we lost and to honor
the selfless heroism of all those on the
front line
we will make sure we learn the lessons
and reflect and prepare but
learning lessons does not mean admitting
mistakes
do you really not reflect on whether
some of those 100
000 deaths could have been prevented if
you'd made decisions
differently we did everything that we
could to
minimize suffering a minimized loss of
life in this
country as a result of the pandemic and
i'm deeply sorry for
every uh every every law every life
lost what i can say
is that the government will continue uh
to do everything we can
to minimize life lost as as we go
forward others take a different view on
past decisions so simon do you think
that there was too much household mixing
in december the facts as we see it in
the health service are that on christmas
day
we had 18 000 coronavirus positive
patients and now we've got just under 33
000. we've seen that growth rippling up
from the southeast
london to the east of england and then
up to the midlands which is consistent
with the spread of the new variant
of the virus and it's that new variant
which the chief medical officer has told
me
substantially changed the situation the
thing which we have which has made
things very different
in 2021 has been the problems of the new
variant and that was not predictable in
september
although that is something we are trying
to do something uh to address now and
you know that's the reason
we were worried two weeks ago that the
measures we had at the moment
were not enough to hold this new variant
the rates are just about holding
with the new variant with what everybody
is doing our big worry
uh it was that that wouldn't even be
able to hold it it's going to be much
harder because this new variant and i
think we have to be realistic about that
the labour leader also trying to capture
the mood but now from isolation
it's a national tragedy this is a master
that nobody
wanted to hit that number of 100 000 is
twice
the number we lost in the blitz and it's
the size of
you know small towns across the united
kingdom
on sunday it will be a year since the
first
uk cases were identified this hasn't
just been a medical emergency a health
crisis
we nearly lost a prime minister we've
been to lock down for the first time
since the second world war
three times we've nearly borrowed 400
billion pounds to cope with the
consequences kids
haven't been in school for six of the
last 10 months some of them
we've put the nhs under unprecedented
strain
twice the different kingdoms of the
united kingdom have come under
unprecedented pressure this has reshaped
our futures
we're facing a different future because
of all the predictions made and
milestones reached over the last 12
months
if we can get this down to numbers
20 000 and below that's a
a good outcome in terms of where we
would hope to get to with this outbreak
but by april the 20 000 figure had
already been breached
the speed was unnerving and it all began
here in york
with the first case seen on january the
31st
2020. never in a million years did we
believe
that 100 000 people will be dead a year
on
so it's alarming and worrying and very
concerning
they were talking about a few thousand
at the most no i wouldn't have imagined
that at all it's awful
awful boris johnson said today he
accepted
full responsibility but he also insisted
he did everything he could to save lives
the british public will be the judge of
that sam coates sky news